[Music]
iagra was discovered by accident but its
impact has been
[Music]
huge the search for something to help
men get it up is as old as history
itself from eating roasted wolf penis to
Electric sharks to Silicon implants
inserted into the shaft you name it it's
been tried but the story of how Viagra
was discovered was quite unexpected it's
the early 1990s a number of men in a
tria s denail a drug to treat handina
report an anticipated side effects
erections lots of them the urban myth
which happens to be true is that the men
who who had it refused to return their
unused tablets because their sex lives
improved so much the first clinical
trials for it as an erection drug are
held in Swans in
1994 and it was clear then after the
first patient that we had something
special then so we had these ordinary
middle-aged Swansea men able to have sex
for the first time in years after just
taking a tablet and four years later
Viagra as it's now known comes to Market
before the '90s the condition Viagra
cont treat was known as impotence which
is not a great word if you're trying to
sell a drug to men as it literally means
lacking in power so the marketing team
hones in on a new term erectile
dysfunction and enlists key figures
including Brazilian Superstar football
of Pelle and US presidential candidate
Bob Dole to open up and normalize
erection difficulties particularly for
older men Viagra the little blue diamond
becomes one of the fastest selling drugs
ever men who struggle for years with
their erections but have been too afraid
to talk about it finally had something
that could help just like erections
studies into erection difficulties can
vary widely and are often unreliable one
UK study found that around 8% of men
under 44 had had trouble getting or
keeping an erection older men are far
more likely to be affected the figure
Rises to 30% for men age 65 to 74 it's
strongly associated with health
conditions like cardiovascular disease
and diabetes and also depression and
life events such as unemployment and
relationship difficulties some arue
Viagra was as revolutionary as the
introduction of the contraceptive pill
but others disagree instead of opening
up discussions around sex critics a
vagra has doubled down on a really
narrow idea of what sex is and
reinforced stereotypes of masculinity
take the porn industry before Viagra
male actors would be chosen for their
ability to get hard and stay hard they
were known as Woodsman but porn films
were more realistic and often featured
flaccid penises too because that's the
reality Viagra turbocharged all
that now it's younger harder more
athletic men sex scenes are longer
rougher and involve more penetration
this adds to the expectation that men's
role in sex is to get hard and perform
so many younger men have performance
anxiety stress plays a huge role in
inhibiting erections so ironically
stressing about erections can make it
harder to get hard it's actually normal
not to be hard all the time and when we
talk about hard how hard do we mean not
all sexual activities require a rock
hard penis and if we really want a hard
penis all the time we can buy one and
keep it in a
drawer if you want to have a good sex
life then talking about sex with your
partner trying new things and being
comfortable about what your body can and
can't do is the best way to get there so
did Viagra change the world or just
double down on how it was and just a
selenop to use its clinical name again
was never originally intended as a drug
to help with hardons it could have some
other potential uses too one small study
found promising evidence to suggest it
could help with period pain but efforts
to explore this further have never been
funded and early studies suggest it
could potentially be useful in treating
Alzheimers so could Viagra change the
world in a totally different way watch
this
space thanks for watching if you enjoyed
that be sure to check out these videos
next and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video